20-19 quarterback class this is not
every quarterback who was drafted that
year just some of them and plenty of
them got a chance to play last year one
name in particular did not play much but
he is a major focal point heading into
2020 let's go through some of these guys
with what we think they're floor and
ceiling would be for 2020 and let's
start with the guy who was the Offensive
Rookie of the Year Kyler Murray Chris
I've made it clear I know that he could
be the fourth straight second-year
quarterback who takes the NFL by storm
Carson Wentz did it in 2017 then Patrick
mahomes in 2018 Lamar Jackson last year
I think it can be kala Merri this year
we met with Kliff Kingsbury the coach of
the Cardinals at the Scouting Combine
and he's in that same camp that there
could be a huge dramatic jump that makes
Kyler Murray the NFL's next big thing
this year yeah I'm with you you know I
mean you know when I saw this exercise
we were doing you know you think about
the ceiling for Kyler Murray you know
it's to me it's and I think I'm with you
Mike it's kind of in that MVP
conversation you know I don't think
Arizona will be good enough for him to
win the MVP that's what just you know my
gut tells me look at it the you know the
the roster on paper at this point and
their division and everything but I look
at the ceiling for Kyler Murray is going
he gets MVP votes I mean he's in the
conversation this year that that's what
I think ultimately I look at it and I
don't know bike but I look at the floor
I think the floor is like a little bit
like where we what we saw this year
where we just went okay yeah it was a
good year
you know it was a great year I don't
want to say that but like statistically
20 touchdowns
you know double-digit interceptions I
think that's about as bad as it could
get and I don't really imagine that
happening really people were mad than he
was offensive rookie of the year there
were a lot of folks who thought Raiders
running back Josh Jacobs should have
gotten it I think that Murray was the
Offensive Rookie of the Year and I agree
with you it's just a question of how
much he builds upon what he did last
year what he did last year is a given
I'd be stunned by a regression from
commentary the question is how much
higher can he pushes perform
and look MVP is tough because it's going
to go to the best player typically on
one of the two teams that emerge with
the top seed and now the top right has
even greater importance because that's
the only seed per conference it gets a
buy I think it's going to cause the
voters to gravitate even more towards
somebody from one of the top two seeds
it's gonna be very difficult for the
Cardinals to emerge with the top seed in
the NFC given the division that they're
assigned to the Giants most likely will
not have the top seed in 2020 Daniel
Jones a controversial top ten pick you
came around on Daniel Jones and a lot of
other people did as well let's figure
out where his ceiling and his floor may
be for the coming season Chris how good
can he be Oh Daniel Jones I really did I
mean yeah it was probably one of the
most egregiously wrong draft evaluations
I ever did I'm in full transparency
there's no doubt about it he crapped all
over what I thought about him in the
draft he was phenomenal last year you
know Mike again I look at Daniel Jones
and you know I think the ceiling I look
at like Pro Bowl votes I don't think
maybe Pro Bowl was realistic but Pro
Bowl votes I do and opening up a lot of
eyes to where we go whoa
this guy he can throw that ball and make
some big-time plays and you know he's
got some good receivers around him not
great but I think that's kind of the
floor that type of I mean the ceiling
that's a conversation the floor you know
again I don't see the the like the
wheels falling off here I don't know how
you feel about it but I think like the
floor I look at a year of like okay the
Giants are mediocre and he still has
some turnover issues alright I think
that's where I would look at is the
floor but I don't think it's gonna be
like oh my gosh we've made a horrible
mistake that we need to think about
making another quarterback draft pick
here sometime in the next few years no I
don't see that happening
and look say Quan Berkeley the guy who I
think if used properly allows Daniel
Jones to flourish because it it draws
extra defenders up toward the line of
scrimmage create some favorite matchups
in the passing game and Jason Garrett is
the offensive coordinator we talked
about this a few weeks ago people cringe
at the idea of Jason Garrett being the
offensive coordinator
Giants when you think about what he
accomplished as an offensive coordinator
maybe you shouldn't cringe maybe the
problems with Jason Garrett were more
about trying to be both head coach and
offensive play designer I think so same
time focusing solely on the one job with
with talent that is it's not apples to
apples and I don't want to suggest like
the Giants have an offensive line
anywhere close to what the the Cowboys
had but you've got a great getting
better Cowboys did and you've got a
quarterback who can be very good like
the Cowboys did and that that is an
ingredient in all of this that will
contribute to Danny Jones performance I
agree with you he's a guy who could be
fringe Pro Bowler as the the ceiling and
you know the floor would just be it just
doesn't work with Jason Garrett it just
all falls apart that did it he knew he
and Garrett just don't see eye to eye
they don't mesh I don't see that
happening but you know that to me it I
could see I'd see a regression for him
before a regression for Kyler Murray do
you agree with that I would agree with
that yes I do you know Colin Murray you
know just you know Kliff Kingsbury being
in that offense really for throughout
his college career into the NFL the
weapons he has a random Kyler Murray I
think it'll be hard for him to fail
especially statistically and things like
that
you know Daniel Jones yeah I'm with you
I don't expect anything bad either
and I really mike i think you make a
good point with the jason garrett thing
you know this is gonna be a he'll be
able to use a similar formula that he
used with that cowboy offense you're
right not the greatest offensive line or
not as good as dallas but certainly
better to be able to run the football
has a really good tight end and Evan
Engram you know Darius Slayton was
impressive as a rookie last year he was
kind of a hidden gem for them so I do
expect big things yeah I don't expect
them to light the world on fire though
because I don't think the Giants will be
good enough to do that quite yet alright
Washington quarterback Dwayne Haskins
the 15th overall pick last year behind
Murray and Jones eventually played kind
of a mixed bag and and and there are
questions about how prepared he really
was dysfunctional teams do dysfunctional
things I think somebody put a
quarterback in an organization like that
and you're not going to have a stellar
performance right away but now with Ron
Rivera
err and Ron Rivera's been ambivalent
about Dwayne Haskins what what's what's
the best-case scenario for Haskins this
year as he gets accustomed to a new
coaching staff well I think just staying
on the field for 16 weeks and having
success you know and if that means you
know 25 touchdowns and 12 interceptions
and that's a great year you know Doane
Haskins still yes I mean he's young he
hasn't played a ton of football he only
played one year at Ohio State so he's
still learning the position he's still
growing into being a young man you know
he's so there is talent there there's no
doubt but it's raw and you know it's raw
I think all across the board you know
mica the one thing I keep hearing with
Dwayne Haskins this year too as much as
I love his talent is oh he's really in
shape well that tells you that he must
have not been in great shape to begin
with you know so those aren't things
like you know franchise quarterbacks
they're OCD type a type people they
never get out of shape Brady doesn't go
home and go well I'm gonna let my beer
my beer belly grow out and then I'll get
back and shape after no he never stops
and you know those are the things I
think Twain Haskins has got to learn but
I think like that's the ceiling to me
it's not a great support system there
they have some building of that offense
ago you know the floor mike is the fact
that he maybe gets benched and a guy
like will Grier he does have to come in
and play a handful of games or whatever
it may be but I think that's generally
the area where I feel it will be at you
know as funny as you explained that it
reminded me of a story that Jameis
Winston told early in his career he
stumbled his way into a Pro Bowl berth
as others tapped out and you know as he
was at the buffet eating bacon and eggs
he saw guys like Russel Wilson coming
back from an intense workout and the
light bulb went off for him if I'm ever
gonna be anything in the NFL I've got my
dress off to this there's there's no
vacations it's your life it's your
lifestyle it's what you do right every
single day to get your body to the point
where it has to be where it needs to be
so you can be as effective as you can be
and I agree with you on Dwayne Haskins I
look if he's just the starter all year
long that's a win I don't expect them to
be a superstar this is all about proving
that you belong and then building on
that in 2021 and the the the the floor
would just be he
it's benched he gets been or anyone
other than to Wayne Haskins and and I
know that Kyle Allen from the Panthers
who was traded to Washington's in the
mix Alex Smith still wants to play but
we'll see how that goes
20:19 class of quarterbacks we talked
earlier in the program about calimary
Daniel Jones Dwayne Haskins the three
first-round picks and all three saw some
playing time last year with Murray being
the NFL's Offensive Rookie of the Year
let's move on to Drew Locke for us he's
a guy that you and I both believed in
and one of the reasons I believed in him
is because you were so so sure of his
ability is that dynamic that we often
see where if a quarterback had left a
year earlier when the team was better he
would have been drafted higher in that
amazing that that becomes a factor in
the evaluate order back the team isn't
good as last year so he falls down the
board because of it even though it's the
same damn guy but that's good for the
Broncos they didn't have to use a
first-round pick on him they traded down
from number 10 with the Steelers they
didn't take him in the lower spot in
round one they were able to get him at
number 42 and now after after plenty of
swings and misses by John Elway he's got
a quarterback they can build around and
I think the the ceiling for drew Locke
is Pro Bowl this year yeah based upon
what we saw at the end of last season
I'm with you I mean I think you know I
don't know if I'll go as strong to say
Pro Bowl but I think Pro Bowl votes are
in that conversation you know that
you've got a game that you know reminds
me of Matt Stafford in a lot of way the
guy can he can reel the ball pops out of
his hands this is an explosive arm and
he can throw the ball a lot of different
ways off his back foot sidearm you know
on the run whatever it may be so I do
think he is a guy that could be one of
those names like as far as the ceilings
concerned where we're going man drew
Locke is he's a super star on the rise
watch out for this kid he you know has
the potential to be in my top ten next
year in the quarterback rankings all
those type of things
ceiling you know I mean the floor Mike I
don't know where are you out of the
floor the floor conversation I go like
okay a lot of turnovers I don't think
he's gonna get benched or anything like
that but maybe careless with the ball
and how
a year where he throws 23 touchdowns and
18 interceptions and maybe they lose a
game or a few games because of his
carelessness that's the me where I see
the floor or if he just doesn't mess
with Pat Shermer right
I mean Pat Shermer did a great job as
offensive coordinator in Minnesota good
enough to become the head coach of the
Giants it lasted just a couple of years
just like his previous stint as a head
coach with the Browns and and one of the
things that resonates with me about Pat
Shermer Mike Holmgren who hired him to
be the coach in Cleveland gives Pat
Shermer a hard time for being too
intense Mike Holmgren of all people one
of the most intense coaches that that
has ever patrolled a sideline thinks Pat
Shermer needs to lighten up Francis so
that that's just you know if we're
trying to find things that we can can
point to where it can go off the rails
I mean if Shermer and lock just don't
mesh that's one of the things that could
cause it to not work and then maybe lock
to regresses over that that that
brilliant strong but we saw we saw a lot
of positive when they beat the Texans
that was so remarkable the Texans are a
playoff team and they went in there and
they thumped the Texans and he was
having fun he's doing the buzz lightyear
thing he was just a joy that we don't
often see from quarterbacks it just it's
the kind of thing you want to see and
and so yeah I expect to see more of that
this year I hope this year that this
year the Broncos fans deserve that after
some down years but you know one of the
things that can cause it to go haywire
is if he and Shermer just don't see eye
to eye yeah I know you're right and I
would be shocked does that happen
you know first off I'm a fan of the Pat
Shermer offense I am and then you know I
know we've talked about this a lot but
Mike Munchak being the offensive
offensive line coach there and then hey
just like we've talked about than any of
these guys Mike and that's why I think
we put drew lock maybe in the Pro Bowl
conversation we talked about the ceiling
is he's got a support system you know
they're fixing the offensive line it's
Melvin Gordon to fill the Blinn see it
running back you know it's Jerry Judy
and Sutton and KJ handler and Noah fan
as your receivers or targets to throw
the football to so you know again I
would not be shocked if we walked away
from this year and went
and Denver got it into the wildcard
playoffs drew Locke was statistically
one of the best quarterbacks in football
and you know was drawing close to 5,000
yards or something like that I wouldn't
be shocked to see any of that type of
stuff this year he has that type of
talent I think the coaching is good and
then of course the talent on that feels
good to where I think they can win some
football games and be dangerous in the
AFC the wild-card in all of this is
Jared Stidham a guy who didn't play much
if at all last year in the regular
season maybe just a cameo appearance we
did the breakdown last week based upon
preseason game against the Giants what
is the ceiling and the floor for the one
guy that we'll be talking about on this
list that didn't do enough last year in
the regular season for us to even have a
basis for dissing oh how good or bad he
could be no you're right I mean though
another guy that just he's just like
drew Locke Mike just like you talked
about with Drew Locke if he leaves two
years earlier you know the same year we
talked about drew Locke leaving Jared
cinema's gonna be one of the top 40
picks of the draft I have no doubt about
that but Auburn fell apart and then they
all blame Jared Stidham and then he fell
down the draft boards because of that
which is just so stupid but you know I
don't know if New England's offense has
the capability or the personnel right
now to be like really really explosive
and you know take take the NFL by storm
but points and yards and all of that so
I think the way I look at the ceiling of
Jared cinema's him being a starting
payoff quarterback I think that's very
capable where yes he's not blowing us
out of the water but we go man guy keeps
making big throws in big moments they
keep winning games you know yeah it
might not be for 350 yards and three
touchdowns that might be a lot of like
you know Tom Brady
early career type games where you go hey
he was 17 for 25 for 225 yards and two
touchdowns and no interceptions
and they won the football game and when
he needed to make big throws he did it I
think that's how I look at the ceiling
with Jared sit him what about you yeah I
mean the ceiling is he steps right in
and runs the offense and you know if you
kind of blur your eyes a little bit it
kind of looks like Tom Brady back there
now right last week a a degree of
bility a level of speed that Tom Brady
has never possessed if if in when Jared
Stidham has to get out of the pocket and
run the ball and and as you've said the
arm isn't as strong as Brady's was but
if he can run the offense I mean this is
gonna be the real test and and this is
gonna be the theme all year long is it
Brady without Belichick is it Bella
check without Brady what can Belichick
and Josh McDaniels do with Jared Stidham
to turn him into a quarterback that can
make the Patriots competitive in their
division and with that extra playoff
berth now available in each conference
can they at least be the number seven
seed it's been a long time since they
haven't made the playoffs the last time
that happened was the year they lost Tom
Brady week one they still went 11 and
five with Matt Cassel but they didn't
make it to the postseason the difference
this time they've got months to get
ready to go without Tom Brady last time
around it happened week one of the
regular season
this time it happened first day of free
agency so they can't say they weren't
ready Chris and they can't say they
didn't have opportunities cuz still one
of those guys is out there the guy
that's not that's not on a team who will
be unveiled very high on your list of
the top quarterbacks in the NFL is
available if they wanted him they could
find a way to get Cam Newton they're
deliberately choosing to shy away from
him and embracing Jared Stidham so it
tells me they believe in Stidham which
he asked me that the ceiling the ceiling
is the Patriots just kid the Train just
keeps on rolling yeah that's exactly
right and you know and again I bet a lot
of people you know Jared Stidham I had
him in my 30s as far as the quarterback
rankings I had a lot of people ask me
like hey who's the guy in the 30s that
you could think you think can make the
biggest jump you know from this year to
next year and Jared said it was the guy
that jumps out to me again you know you
saw some of the plays we watched last
week a preseason football and you
watched him last year in the preseason
to begin with anyways you know the kids
got talent he really does he can do it
all in the football field and he's a
really good down the field thrower and
he can make plays when nothing's there
to be had you know so hey this is this
is plan a for New England they believe
instead of and don't be shocked if he's
still the quarterback seven or eight
years from now I think that's how they
see this unfolding you know the
offensive lines got to play better we
know that
they got Marquis Lee in free agency
Damir bird Nikhil Harry they need him to
show up as a first round pick still got
Julian Edelman so there's a decent
support system there for him to make
things happen and I think they'll play
for their through their defense what do
you think the floor is I mean the floor
I guess is it just it's roughing it ruff
and Brian we're ended up coming in or is
the bench
the floor is ranch right that it's just
not working and Bill Belichick is not
going to take all season to admit it if
it's not working it's not working and in
comes bran Hoyer period so he won't
exactly he will not hesitate and that's
how he's always been you you earn your
way onto the field and you earn your
ability to stay on the field and if
you're not earning it we're gonna find
somebody else we've got somebody else
we've got Brian Hoyer and he comes real
quickly real quickly Gardner Minshew
nobody expects anything out of the
jaguars this year this is an ideal
scenario the bar is as low as it could
be for men shoe and the Jaguars so I
mean the floor is they live up to
everyone's expectation that they're
gonna be the worst team in the NFL the
ceiling is they could surprise a lot of
people if it clicks yes I mean the
ceiling is he could put up unbelievable
numbers and they could be a really
explosive offense and he could throw for
30 touchdowns and seven or eight
interceptions you know we talked about
earlier in the show there's weapons
there you know decent old lion got some
running backs Jay Gruden's there you
know he's capable of making some plays
there's no doubt about that so you know
I think the ceiling is just the
continuation of Mynt you meet mania and
like and I would say Pro Bowl votes too
you know it's hard to make the Pro Bowl
in the AFC because there's kind of some
good quarterbacks you know labarda sean
patrick Mahone's but you know votes
possible certainly yeah floor is okay
gardner minshew you're not the guy and
we're gonna be looking for a quarterback
in the draft next year that's kind of
how I see a plant but gardner minshew
has got a chance to prove himself to be
the guy for Jacksonville for a lot of
years to come
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports